I'm just going to use myself as the
first example or a regular income
because for most it means yep I have
what you call a salary of salaries does
anyone know what a salary is how would
you define it in a nice crease to think
extensive smelly
I found something in fact except of
acquittal was that Dell together and
into teaching they're number one that
it's big it's a fixed amount of money
and it's generally speaking per year
even if you only work say my my brother
Princeton season ID contract up he might
get a contract is only six month long
but it gets quoted of salary which is an
annual sellers right fixed amount per
year perfect you might work more you
might work less but because it speaks it
doesn't matter your CV same salary there
is a client of regular income that does
change though based on how much you able
to collect wages record is still
somewhat fall under this category of
regular income because generally
speaking you might be working okay we've
got you as a part-time worker at this
drop you don't just like blow in and
blow out your there for a number of
bucks but you work more hours you earn
more income so running keeps the melt
code geass how would you articulate how
to express that lots of things
yeah
almost like yeah so usually we say this
is a fixed amount by our not by doea
right
so you often hear about an hourly rate
this is how much I earn per hour and
then the more hours you caught up to
more get paid now on this idea of wages
I want to read off a little bit because
if you earn wages there are things you
can do which attracts special amounts of
money the first thing is for example
well over the top okay so over time now
think about what this means okay
the idea of overtime is we expect you to
work roughly some number of hours per
week maybe 30 hours that's a part-time
job okay but they might say actually
this week we need to do they make a bit
later we need you to work on clothes
again my brother used to work at Pizza
Hut they do the 1:00 a.m. closing shift
and people aren't in their ordering
papers cleaning up that's in action at a
time and in the track more money what
other ways if you're in a wage job could
you attract more money think about when
yeah okay
so I'm not going to give a number on his
level come to a decision but you can
have double pay what we call the time
you can also have time in a hole okay
all of these come under things like a
weekend if you work on a Saturday or
Sunday or public
okay now depending on the job you're in
depending on the employer for each of
these you will get some combination of
for example suppose you're getting paid
$10 an hour okay
actually he's gonna pass on junkies time
job yeah okay so on Ellen what're you
getting paid to move her out here 1194 I
can't stop if you have to say right
let's I know how to exactly the same
right all different yes I will just
stick with this oh very pretty
this room gets paid one of that we ready
think it's a much higher give it IV 11
various words we don't want indicative
of what go so what you're going to read
if we were working some public holidays
there are different shops that are open
in different shops that I close okay so
a classic example would be say Boxing
Day what the place are actually perfect
for walking there so they actually
employ people almost on the quality so
if we're learning this amount normally
double time instead of getting this per
hour what would you get 2388 obviously
you can check to discuss it on this
thing until that double time so I'm
going to write that here but those are
2388 except for Harry that's a lot of
money
so sometimes it's not quite willing to
pay it that much so they're doing in
between it's been at this time to
they'll multiply it by 1.5 that's still
better than what you're normally getting
but it's not a suitable time we call
that because it's this and a half we
call it time a half
edge excellent medicine yeah
here's the way it works right if you
have a normal six hour shift but you're
getting paid double time it's as if you
have not six hours but 12 hours at our
pool no time and if you were getting
paid at Andujar but you work together
you get paid as work nine our services
young but it